and get the left-hander marco gonzalez
starting for the mariners here tonight
it'll be his 10th start of the season
5.10 era that is in
47 and two-thirds innings he has allowed
10 home runs this year so the long ball
has been a problem 42 strikeouts to 18
walks for this left-hander he's much
more of a fly ball pitcher today connor
philipe isaiah did
pinch run last night swinging a fly ball
straight away center field right there
taylor trammell in his tracks and he
makes the catch
diner falefa flies out and there's one
down
right away eli white is next hitting
209.
and that is a mile high pop-up in the
silo
murph is under it stayed with it well
done
and two down for the rangers here on the
top of the first
inning here's center fielder and dolis
garcia
hit hard out to left field and friendly
again
coming in with a headlong lunge but he
trapped that
i don't think he caught it garcia is on
and it gets nate low to the plate
secret throw over the rangers are gone
here in the top of the first inning nice
start for marco
the rangers sending jordan lyles to the
mound and his last couple of times out
he's been really good he's been really
good listen all the ranger starters have
thrown the ball pretty well here lately
but jordan lyles in particular
shortstop jp crawford leading off the
bottom of the first inning
and he shoots this one out to center
field garcia
stuck right in his tracks makes a catch
and that's out number one there's one
away no score for mitch henniger
and that's bounced to third base
culverson
fires the strike across the infield and
hannigar retired and here's kyle siegel
swinging a heartache round ball right
side into the shift diving to his right
so
that can't get to it and it's through
the shift into right field a base hit
for seeger
mariners with their first hit that'll
bring up first baseman ty france
the bouncer left side of the infield
long throw for kind of pull up it's high
and obama has brought it down but
couldn't get the tag on france
there goes zabanya's coming up and he
gets way up to get that comes down oh
look like he might have got france
on that shoulder perhaps the rangers
will take a look at this they will ask
for a challenge he'll be out he should
be out there
and it's now overturned it's an hour
of 6-3 put out into the inning gonzalez
he's a proud new papa had a baby girl
it's been 12 days
since he's taken the mouse swinging a
missing a fastball for strike three
and that is strikeout number one for
marco gonzalez
one away for the rangers here in the top
of the second that'll bring up second
baseman nick solak
swing and a miss at a fastball that was
up strike three so back-to-back
strikeouts for marco gonzalez
banning ibanez and now solac here in the
top half of the second two away
the mariners have runners and first and
third with two outs
that'll bring up taylor travel 2-2 and
that's in the dirt did he go yes he did
and tremel who strikes out in about half
his plate appearances has struck out
to end the inning john hicks to lead
things off hitting a home run in his
first game
as a ranger high drive well hit deep out
into left field friendly doesn't even
move
this one sails way out of here john
hicks with his second home run and his
many starts for the rangers and texas
leads it one to nothing
texas in business here already one run
across and runners at first
and second and nobody out here comes eli
white great chance to put up a crooked
number here
the first offering to eli white is
drilled into deep left fraley going back
it's over his head and just over the
wall
and eli white with a three-run homer
four-nothing rangers runners at the
corners with two away
and here comes david dahl the only
ranger not to bat here in the inning
strike three called he got him strike
three down he goes and that's the inning
but damage done a single a hit by pitch
and a walk and that brings up
ty france after the rangers gave him
four
runs in the top of the third lyles has
come out
and loaded him up with nobody out here's
the pitch to tie
low ball four and he's walked in her on
jp crawford will score from third the
mariners get their first run of the ball
game a bases loaded walk to tai france
and they're still cooking here comes
jake fraley the hero from last night
with the bases still
loaded and nobody out and the fastball
left up
and that one looped into left white
coming on and makes a sliding grab
and they will not advance oh that's a
big time play in left field to get to
that ball make sure
he caught it there comes dylan moore
mariners trailing by
three payoff got him swinging that's a
huge strikeout two away
so now jordan lyle just won her away
from escaping
what could have been and still could
potentially be
a really rough inning and this ball hit
out to
deep center field that could be trouble
but garcia is there and the inning is
over
oh my bowers comes within a few
feet of a grand slam that would have put
seattle
in front instead it is a loud long
final out john hicks leading off again
in this frame after we saw a solo shot
in the third
he's enjoying the chance to make an
impact right away with this call-up
that ball crushed will it stay fair
it is gone john hicks
two for two two home runs leaning off
and inning
rangers lead it five to one brings up
adolesce garcia who's swinging a good
bat tonight let's go golfed
out to left field that one gets down and
rolls to the wall it dies out there
adolesce garcia drives in a pair it's
7-1 rangers one out in the bottom of the
fifth and here's kyle seeger who is
singled and walked swinging a drive deep
to straight away center field
garcia going back looking up and goodbye
baseball out to the batter's eye i'm
telling you he loves hitting against the
texas rangers
and it's now the rangers seven and the
mariners two
lyle's interestingly out in this sixth
inning
that caught me a little by surprise with
the pitch count over 100.
struck him out swinging as jordan wins
the battle with the slider
a 10 pitch strikeout to finish off his
evening
and the mariners have two on in scoring
position
trying to chip away at a five-run
deficit here is jake braley
garcia is right there tagging seeger
he'll score france wow what a third
third
i'll say holy mackerel wow
now the rangers seven in the mariners
three josh spores
to try and finish it off the
hard-throwing right-hander takes over
this will be his 33rd game of the season
mariners are down to their final out
here in the bottom of the ninth inning
this one popped up that's playable that
could be the ball game
and ibanez makes the play that will do
it
and so the rangers take a 7-3 win from
seattle
and they have ended their seattle losing
streak
[Applause]